ثالث من يناير من العام المقبل نقطه بدايه
لتحقيقات بشان اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عندما يتسلم الجمهوريون منصه قياده
مجلس النواب الدور الثامن عشر بعد المئه
للكونجرس الامريكي قد يطغى عليها تشكيل
لجان تحقيق مع عددا من مسؤولي الاداره
بعدما وعد بعض من الجمهوريين بذلك اذا
قالت اليهم اغلبيه الغرفه الادنى من
الكونجرس الملف الاول سيكون مع ملف الهجره
غير القانونيه عبر الحدود الجنوبيه
للولايات المتحده والذي كان محوره اهتمام
للناخبين الجمهوريين خلال الانتخابات
النصفيه
فوضى الحدود بحسب الجمهوريين يرى مراقبنا
انها ستكون منطلقا للحزب الجمهوريه للوصول
الى بلدي محاكمه جوبيدا باعتباره اكبر
مسؤول في الاداره بحسب رئيس المرتقب لمجلس
النواب كافي
يوتيوب
مكارثي طلب وزير الامن الداخليه اليخاندرو
مايوركاس بالاستقاله والا واجه اسابيع من
التحقيقات امام لجان الكونجرس ومن مدينه
الباسو والحدوديه مع المكسيك قال مكارثي
ان الحدود شهدت في عهد مايوركاس دخول
اعداد كبيره من من هم على لوائح مراقبه
الارهاب اضافه الى مرور كميات قياسيه من
المخدرات شمالا باتجاه الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
كفر كفر
وزير الامن الداخلي
قال انه لا يخطط لمغادره منصبه بحسب بيان
للوزاره قبل التحقيقات المتوقعه معه امام
الكونجرس ذات الاغلبيه الجمهوريه بدوره
اعتبر البيت الابيض ان الجمهوريين ليست
لديهم خطه لتحسين الوضع وكاله المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض كاري جون بيار ان
الجمهوريين يقومون فقط بممارسه الاعب
سياسيه على حد قورها لكن في الكواليس تحدث
مسؤول في البيت الابيض لتقى بمحامي
الاداره الامريكيه مع مسؤولين وزاره الامن
الداخليه للبدائي في الاستعداد للتحقيق مع
الوزير مايوركاست فيما يتوقع ان يكون
واحدا من عده تحقيقات متعلقه باداره بيدن
الحديث في الجانب الجمهوري عن ازمه الهجره
امر تدركه الاداره وايضا وزاره الامن
الداخلي عندما طلب مايوركاس من مدير هيئه
الحدود والجمارك الاستقاله قبل ايام وكما
هو الحال مع الوزير مايوركاست رفض المسؤول
كريسماس الاستقاله رغم ابلاغه بانه
سيطردوا ان لم يغادر بمفرده الى ان ردخ
مانجو ماغنوس للامر الواقع وفي وقت لاحق
اصدر البيت الابيض بيانا يشكر فيه ماجنس
على مسيرته المهنيه التي استمرت 40 عاما
في الخدمه العامه